[Musica]
dai 16 ai 26 anni ho vissuto sempre con
un grande senso di inadeguatezza
dovunque andassi io non mi sentivo mai
all'altezza della situazione
essere stato abbonata alle superiori non
ha aiutato la mia autostima perché per
me è stato come se qualcuno fosse
arrivato dall'alto a dirmi che i tool è
questo tuo che non vali niente
così una volta diplomata possesso di
perdere ingegneria perché volevo
dimostrare a me stessa che non ero
stupida e se suona persona che a scuola
non va tanto bene scegliere una facoltà
complessa come ingegneria è l'ultima
decisione che poi prende nella pro vita
la decisione più stupida che poi
prendere nella tua vita perché ogni
volta che uscivo da una lezione io non
avevo capito niente e questo ha fatto sì
che mi sentissi sempre più stupida
sempre più inadeguata sempre più non
all'altezza
ho iniziato a pensare che avrei mai
potuto fare niente di significativo
nella mia vita mi sentivo una fallita
nel pensiero comune
non andare bene a scuola e non andare
bene all'università vuol dire
ma veri problemi con il mondo del lavoro
mentre andare bene a scuola e andare
bene all'università è associato ad avere
un futuro più facili neonato beh nel
mondo che cambia alla velocità di oggi
velocità a cui non sta cambiando la
scuola e velocità a cui non cambia
l'università come ben scuole come varie
università non saranno mai
le uniche variabili per definire quello
che farai da grande
la scuola
ti mette dell'etichetta se non ti
mettere etichette questo non è un
problema ma se ti vuoi mettere le
etichette l'etichetta per primo della
classe come l'etichetta dell'ultimo
della classe sono delle armi a doppio
taglio per chi non aveva pensare di
essere pronto ad affrontare il mondo
mentre l'altra di fa pensare che non
sarai mai abbastanza pronto ad
affrontare il mondo
e ovviamente nessuna delle due è vera e
probabilmente se avessi capito questo
qualche anno prima
avrei risparmiato anni e anni di terapia
però noi oggi siamo qua e siamo qui a
parlare di formazione che siamo qui a
parlare di metamorfosi e se io penso la
mia metamorfosi c'è sicuramente una cosa
che devo farvi vedere anche se ancora
viene vergogno un po
questa ero io nel mio secondo terzo
superiore e persone esattamente il
libretto di scuola del mio secondo verso
superiore e quando io guardo questa
ragazza quando guardo questa bambina mi
chiedo cosa ti ha fatto fare
una trasformazione cosa ti ha cambiato
allora sicuramente aver cambiato
parrucchieri e stata una scelta saggia
però poi accettato di andare un po più a
fondo e ho capito che le cose che mi
hanno aiutato maggiormente ne sono state
le essermi guardata dentro le essermi
messo in gioco è la vera avuto il
coraggio di sognare in grande
a un certo punto ho iniziato a chiedervi
se tutti i tuoi pensieri limitanti
ghiorgos ultimi fossero realmente i miei
fosse in vennero fatti m
perché io dentro di me sentivo la voglia
di fare qualcosa di grande sentivo che
avevano energia però quelle diretta
della bocciata qualità mi bloccava
e tutto quel dolore tutta quella
sofferenza poi però un certo punto mi
sono serviti per che hanno iniziato a
farmi fare delle domande può iniziare a
chiedermi ma poiché se vi va male senso
della tua vita perché sei venuta al
mondo
ovviamente non era la domanda facile a
cui rispondere
però avevo capito una cosa avevo capito
che avevo bisogno di trovare un
obiettivo per la mia vita avevo bisogno
di legare la mia vita a un obiettivo più
grande di me avevo bisogno di quell
obiettivo più grande di me per uscire
dalla modalità sopravvivenza e per
iniziare a vivere
in questo senso la scuola che io avrei
voluto non è quella che ti dà le giuste
risposte ma è quella che meglio da parti
fare le giuste domande
io ho scoperto quando ero già grande il
concetto di ikic ai questa è un'immagine
che racchiude in sé dei concerti
importantissimi io sono sicura che se
noi mettessimo questa immagine dietro le
cattedre di ogni scuola a partire dalle
elementari fino ad arrivare
all'università noi a un certo punto
avremo delle generazioni più consapevoli
perché chi prima chi dopo chi di più chi
meno avremo quasi ogni persona al mondo
ha iniziato a chiedersi
meglio cosa abbiamo
ma io cosa sono bravo
che cosa potrei essere pagato e
soprattutto di cosa
il mondo ha bisogno
io avevo capito una cosa ma dove ho
capito che volevo fare un lavoro che non
fosse soltanto utile a me ma la mia
soddisfazione personale e alla mia
soddisfazione economica
io
volevo fare un lavoro avesse un impatto
positivo sulla società
non sapevo come farlo ovviamente però
una volta laureata a perché poi siamo
fatta per laurearmi
poi iniziato a studiare le tecnologie in
quel momento stavano cambiando il voto
mani può studiare il modo del digitale
in modo del promozione ha iniziato ad
acquisire competenze che ho scoperto
dopo essere molto richieste nel mondo
del lavoro miei tempi li avevano poche
persone
e qui ho capito una cosa
ho capito che quando non riesce a
esprimere il tuo massimo potenziale
nell'estate che tutti indicano
ai due chip
arrenderti può iniziare a cercare nuove
strade
quello che è successo è che nel 2016 mi
si presenta un'occasione lavorativa
abbastanza importante
mi chiesero di entrare a far parte di un
team che stava gestendo la comunicazione
online e offline di un comitato a
livello nazionale non c'è bisogno che vi
dica che non mi sentivo all'altezza di
quel lavoro perché mi sembrava una cosa
troppo grande per me
eppure le competenze ce le avevo e
soprattutto sentivo che era arrivato per
me il momento primi fermi gioco così
accettai
da quel lavoro ho capito una cosa molto
importante ho capito che il mio lavoro
nel digitale poteva avere un impatto su
tantissime persone
e soprattutto in quel lavoro con
obbligherà a quello che poi è diventato
il mio socio mio marito
la persona con cui ogni giorno cerco di
raggiungere mia ppv
io di rado avevamo diverse cose in
comune entrambi avevamo sofferto tanto
per trovare la nostra strada
entrambi eravamo re inventati nel
digitale ed entrambi vogliamo lasciare
un segno positivo nel mondo e ovviamente
infame non avevamo idea di come pablo
però
siamo partiti dalle nostre sofferenze ne
abbiamo iniziato a pire
ma se noi avessimo scoperto tutti questi
mondi anni anni ma quanti anni di
sofferenze ci saremmo risparmiati
metti
abbiamo lasciato i nostri lavori ne
abbiamo iniziato un folle tour nelle
scuole di tutta italia a titolo
completamente gratuito per andare a
raccontare ai giovani quali erano le
nuove professioni che si stavano
sviluppando quali erano tutti quei
lavori che spesso a scuola
all'università non si raccontano
quella da filippo del nostro obiettivo
che noi non sapevamo su quante persone
avrebbe un papato
ma siamo partiti pensando che se fossimo
riusciti a risparmiare le nostre
sofferenze anche solo ad un ragazzo noi
ne saremmo stati felici
quello che abbiamo scoperto un anno
nelle scuole che dieci anni dopo non era
cambiato niente
la maggior parte dei ragazzi non avevano
idea di quali fossero i nuovi lavori
però
vedevamo negli occhi di alcuni una
scintilla chiudiamo la scintilla della
speranza ma quando gli ne andiamo a
raccontare quante nuove opportunità
c'erano ed è stata proprio quella
scintilla che ci ha spinto a non mollare
nei momenti difficili che ci ha spinto
ad andare avanti e così quel tour nelle
scuole diventa tanto nelle università e
dopo poco eravamo riusciti a creare un
nuovo modo per fare formazione online
basato sulla pratica sui lavori del
futuro perché fare pratica perché sia io
che lui ci eravamo resi conto
e stato solo facendo pratica che ci
siamo accorti impose ramo bravi in
consumer oprah non eravamo stati tra
entrambi abbiamo scelto le nostre
carriere sulla carta e quindi ci piaceva
l'idea di aiutare i ragazzi a fare
pratica
dopo qualche anno ci siamo resi conto
avevamo creato una realtà che era
realmente in grado di orientare i
giovani alle nuove professioni era
realmente in grado di formarli e
soprattutto cosa che non ci aspettavamo
quando eravamo partiti
tutte le persone che facevano i percorsi
persona nei corsi poi entravano nel
mondo del lavoro
nel giro di pochi anni avevamo creato
centinaia di posti di lavoro
era tutto bellissimo era tutto perfetto
però purtroppo il terzo punto avere il
coraggio di sognare in grande perché
vogliamo fare qualcosa di più
vogliamo fare un ulteriore passo
io ancora oggi quando dico così alta
voglio cambiare il mondo
vogliono solo un segno positivo nel
mondo
io ho ancora dentro un pazzo di me che
provo vergogna né per la portavoce nera
mi chiedo per thiene
perché abbiamo creato un sistema in cui
voler dire voglio lasciare un segno
positivo è una cosa strana è che abbiamo
creato un sistema in cui voler fare un
cambiamento
è una cosa per pochi
i giovani di oggi vivono in un mondo che
evolve tecnologicamente molto più veloce
di come stiamo evolvendo come esseri
umani
e noi abbiamo la responsabilità di
aiutare i giovani a crescere come esseri
umani
perché le tecnologie sono un mezzo molto
potente e sarà meglio che stanno nelle
mani di persone che hanno una forza
interiore così elevata da riuscire nel
momento in cui si troveranno a scegliere
di riuscire a sé di riuscire a scegliere
gli interessi della collettività invece
del proprio interesse personale
e ci teniamo come come si può fare
questo cambiamento
ma sti abbiamo un'idea abbiamo detto
oggi viviamo in un paradigma per cui tu
scegli in cosa formarti anche lavoro
pari e che lavoro fare in base al
guadagno e se cambiassimo questo modo di
pensare che se ne fossimo non far
tentare ragazzi che le competenze che
stanno acquisendo oggi possono essere un
mezzo per risolvere un problema
e così abbiamo chiesto a tutti i nostri
studenti di scegliere dai 17 obiettivi
di sviluppo sostenibile delle nazioni
unite
quale tra questi obiettivi in quale tra
questi obiettivi avrebbero voluto
applicare le competenze che stavano
acquisendo gli abbiamo chiesto quali la
possibilità di scappare
questa domanda non ti sta chiedendo se
non sei in grado di cambiare il mondo
questa domanda che sta facendo spostare
l'attenzione sul come vuoi farlo e sta
dando per scontato che tu vuoi farlo
perché ci sono tanti modi diversi di
cambiare il mondo camera il mondo può
dire migliorare la vita di una persona
può voler dire migliorare la vita di
milioni di persone non patire
è quello che è successo e che su più di
3.500 studenti
l'ottanta per cento ha impostato un
obiettivo è soltanto un 20 per cento non
ha impostato gli obiettivi ora
io so bene che lo faccia per cento non è
la parità e primi 500 giovani non sono
la totalità però
sogniamo un attimo è grande e pensiamo
che esiste una possibilità esiste una
probabilità in cui in questo momento
l'ottanta per cento di tutti i giovani
nel mondo si sta formando pensando già a
come potrà usare le proprie competenze
per avere un impatto positivo sul mondo
e ben pensare questa cosa
non è soltanto una cosa che mi rende
felice orgogliosa delle nuove
generazioni
ma è una cosa che mi fa dormire un po
più serena vano perché i giovani di oggi
dovranno stron affrontare delle sfide
così grandi che sarà meglio avere
persone consapevoli delle sfide che
bisognerà affrontare e consapevoli che
hanno già iniziato oggi ad avere le
competenze per affrontarle
ovviamente metterli in queste condizioni
sarebbe una risposta rapida di noi a
tutti
la scuola università alle famiglie
però però però
perché questa è l'epoca in cui
l'ignoranza ma questa è l'epoca in cui
non sapere quali sono le tecnologie che
stanno impattando maggiormente sulle
persone che non sapere quali sono i
lavori più richiesti e non sapere quali
sono le sfide che il mondo sta e dovrà
affrontare nei prossimi decenni è una
scelta personale di ogni singolo
individuo
quindi
ragazzi di oggi a voi che voglio parlare
perché
io non so se come quando il sistema
formativo camera però lavoro a contatto
con voi ogni giorno e se c'era una cosa
dico ormai sono certa
è che voi siete la generazione non ha
bisogno di noi
voi siete la generazione che più di ogni
altra ha la forza la voglia e il
coraggio di cambiare il mondo
quindi iniziate da oggi partite da voi
stessi
andate alla ricerca di una missione più
grandi di voi e soprattutto non
aspettate che nessuno divieto emesso di
farlo perché non ne avete bisogno
[Applauso]
[Musica]